let's go next to dylan from
massachusetts dillon welcome
hey david how's it going it's going well
it's good to hear um so if biden were to
by executive order set up abortion
clinics on federal land
in states that have banned abortion do
you think that there's anything that
those states can do to stop those
clinics from functioning you know i i'm
sure that there are things they can try
to do with new arguments that we've not
heard used before
but it would be sort of like a va
hospital in a sense right where
when in fact i remember a story from
growing up in massachusetts where at a
va hospital there was like a nurse that
killed a bunch of patients by
deliberately giving them too much of the
wrong medication
and it was subject to
the death penalty even though
massachusetts didn't have it because it
happened in a federal facility and i
believe that along the same lines if
federal facilities wanted to offer
abortion services even in states that
have banned it i think it would be very
difficult for the state to supersede or
come in and do anything about it i mean
it would have to be tested and there
would be a test but it sounds like it
would be pretty solid
yeah because i've heard arguments um
from people who say that that's a bad
idea for biden to do that by executive
order like for example if a state were
to arrest
like someone
like a doctor going on site before or
after they leave the federal land yep
for having committed the crime of
uh doing an abortion procedure on
federal land like that would get very
dicey that would get extremely dicey
because it's not like a uh it's not like
an embassy right a va hospital a federal
hospital it's not like an embassy where
literally no rules apply
um but yeah i i mean it's it's really a
complicated legal question
yeah if you have if you could snap your
fingers and compel joe biden to set up
these va abortion clinics on federal
land
would you or or would you not
compel him to do that uh i'd have to
think about it i would really have to
think about it i mean the ideal thing
would be to codify roe v wade but that's
not up to biden that's up to democrats
in the senate they don't have the votes
i would want to know more about it
before i took a really strong position
on it
um i i i'm of the same opinion yeah do
you think if um democrats get the votes
after
you know by some miracle this midterm
elections uh do you think that the
supreme court would allow
roe to be codified into law i
from what i've read it would be very
difficult for the supreme court to stop
it
yeah
all right well thanks for taking my call
david all right dylan from massachusetts
very much appreciate the call